he's been covering houston sports since
ken stabler was learning his playbook by
the light of a jukebox
and he also broke quite the story put it
out there that the texans and the
dolphins might consummate a deal for
none other than deshawn watson
sometime this week
from the houston chronicle our friend
johnny mclean back here on the rich
eisen show how are you john
rachel i'm doing great how are you now
i'm doing better for talking to you all
right um i saw your tweet literally
called you within 15 seconds after
seeing your tweet
saying that desean watson and the texans
might part ways this week sending him to
miami i'll give you the floor in your
report john rich as you know their talks
have been ongoing between the texans
general manager
nick casario and his office general
manager chris greer for months they've
had a lot of teams that have showed
interest all wanted resolution of the
legal issues they wanted to know what is
the status the nfl police investigations
would roger goodell suspend him and you
know owner stephen ross would want to
know that from goodell before they do
the deal now the reason the talks
intensified this week could be because
we're getting closer to the november
second trade daylight trade deadline or
it could have been because
the dolphins lost to the jaguars in
london
but i'll tell you this watson has a no
trade clause all those other teams that
have been interested he's told him he'll
he will
give up at no trade clause if he can go
to miami people believe one reason will
fuller his favorite receiver here after
after deandre hopkins was traded the
reason fuller signed with the dolphins
he thought that watson would eventually
end up there there's a lot of moving
parts as you know rich but the bottom
line is they've intensified the efforts
rosario's wanted three ones and two twos
i'm pretty sure he'll get the three ones
don't know if he's come down from the
two twos but uh they'd like to get it
done but the end of the week and if they
don't they'll get it done before the
trading deadline so that's that that's
the question i was going to tell you is
like this week what why the this week
you were you're just hearing that that
um that there's been some positive talks
that they're close i mean because as you
know in the nfl this is a just after
midnight league and midnight again
doesn't strike till the first week of
november
they from what i understand it started
on monday they intensified the efforts
it's been going on all week and i'll
tell you something i saw watson leave
the facility yesterday
i was outside now watson never moves
fast he's always in slow motion except
on the field and i saw him hurry out to
his car and take off and i thought well
that's interesting because he's leaving
earlier than he usually does he comes
here to work he works out on his own he
goes to meetings he lifts weights does
everything he needs to do to be in the
best possible shape for when he is
traded if it's during the season richie
wants to hit the ground running if they
pull it off this week the texans play in
miami on november 7th and i'm excited
about watching j.j watt de'andre hopkins
go against the texans that would be even
better if deshawn watson's first game
against his former team so okay um
lots to lots to pick at here john
mcclane of the houston chronicle his
report that uh a trade for deshaun
watson going to miami could be done as
soon as this week
so um
the the question as to whether watson
would be allowed to play by the nfl the
fact that he's not on the commissioner's
exempt list right now best you can tell
is that because the commissioner knows
there's no reason to do it because
there's no chance on this green earth
that watson will play for the texans and
texans won't have him out there because
they know he can get hurt and thus ruin
any trade that you're talking about
right now or the fact is that if he's
traded that the the commissioner could
just tell the dolphins he's on the
exempt list i mean there's so many
question marks about his availability
should a trade occur
john great job told you for months he
will never take another snap for the
texans he would not do it and they don't
want him to if you think about since he
issued his trade demand through his
people close to watson back right after
last season
you know that's caused this franchise a
lot of trouble because they had a great
young quarterback coming off a
tremendous season in every statistic by
far the best he played he did it without
hopkins he did it without fuller for the
last six games randall cobb for the last
five games randall cobb for six and yet
he continued to play great and so now
they got to start over he wanted to be
gone before nick casario was iron david
culley and then he explained to david
culley early in march that he would hold
out he would never report again and so
that's when they decided to trade him
and eight teams were interested and then
when the legal issues started to pile up
they all withdrew and let the texans
know that
if they were interested in trading him
for less they'd take the problem off
their hands and they were not nick
casario has stuck to his guns to this
point and i do know this they would like
to trade him he would like to be traded
and if they don't get it done by
november 2nd then they're going to wait
all the way to the draft well sure i
don't think they want this continued to
fester well then the problem is is is
about the legal issues what are you
hearing locally there anything
rich has been quiet the attorneys have
been quiet uh usually it was tony busby
firing a broadside rusty hardened
responding they've been quiet don't know
if it means anything and uh but i do
know this stephen ross would not allow
the trade to be pulled off if he didn't
think watson was going to be able to
play and the only way he would know that
is if he talked to the commissioner
remember roger goodell works for him not
vice versa
and so i think when he's traded he'll
play
ah yeah i know roger's worked for a lot
of people who's been very disappointed
with his rulings though john you know
that's that's the thing that's so crazy
that you would make you you would think
that somebody who's got such a business
accurate that his name's all over the
business school and my alma mater at
michigan wouldn't make a trade for
somebody without knowing for sure
concretely his availability
um that's what was so surprising about a
trade that's going to be done during the
season so if it's not this week you
definitely think it's going to happen
before november 2nd i know you mentioned
that it would be done all the way
through to the draft if not but your
your sense of your sense of this is that
it's going to happen
my sense is that deshaun watts will be
playing for the miami dolphins
john mcclane here on the rich eisen show
before i let you go on your busy day the
astros are a game away
from making the world series again
um what's your sense of this team john
and how
they are uh making their way through uh
to uh three games to two lead right now
and usually for four games it was worth
starting pitching the playoffs i've ever
seen could all the four starters
couldn't get to seven innings
and i thought they were done after the
way the red sox just obliterated them in
the second and third game i didn't think
they would win now all of a sudden
they're hitting again from valdez had an
incredible pitching performance last
night as you can imagine people here are
pumped and looks like the well i say the
braves beat the dodgers they had them
down three to one last year and the
dodgers responded but uh people here
didn't think
i don't believe once lance mccullers was
ruled out i don't think people thought
they were gonna beat the red sox and the
big bats that they have but everything
has fallen into place and i think now
they will beat them in one of these next
two games and they will move on to the
world series they showed their
resilience last year when they had to
win three games in a row to go seven
against the rays and then they lost that
last game fell one game short but
they've been very motivated and i think
all the booing and the cheating and the
negativity just fuels this franchise led
by carlos correa who i believe will be
having a new zip code next year
unfortunately for the astronauts yeah i
i know that that said you know correa
has been remarkable and i know him you
know touching his wrist for korea time
is one thing
but the the eighth inning home run in
game four down two to one by jose altuve
i think gets lost in the fact of how
horrible laz diaz was behind home plate
in boston certainly on that one-two
pitch to castro from vivaldi but where
does altuve rank do you think in the
history of houston sports right now
certainly if they pull off this world
series appearance and maybe even the
ultimate john what do you think the two
most popular players in astros history
are jeff bagwell craig biggio both of
whom are in the hall of fame al tuva's
right up there he came here when the
team was awful suffered through those
three consecutive 100 lost seasons
averaging 108 losses during those three
seasons the fans loved him that home run
tied him with derek jeter i believe for
the most home runs hit it clutch time
and he's been
mr clutch and he's not going anywhere
they got him on a favorable contract uh
when he was younger but it's to lose
springer and correa two years in a row i
thought they could never overcome the
springer loss and to think about carlos
correa who's been here since they you
know he was 18 and he was drafted but
they hope a miracle that jim crane the
owner will come up with the money but
every time i see him on base or make a
great play in the field i hear kachin
that's why he's touching his wrist he
should be touching his back pocket so uh
why is career going why is it that it
would be money he said he was insulted
by the 20 million a year offer they put
out there
25 and he's tight with lindor and lindor
signed that contract what was it like
327 million he's friends with top teeth
he saw the tati's deal and correa wright
would be 27 as an unrestricted free
agent it seems like he's been around
longer than that he had injury issues
the previous three years he did some
different things about his back and he's
been healthy this season and one of the
things rich that's most disappointing if
they lose gray he is i've never seen a
better leader things he does behind the
scenes i'm told things he does in a
dugout on the mound he is a tremendous
leader and i read something yesterday
the yankees could use a shortstop but
could but could they sign him
considering the fans those fans would
eat up having carlos correa as their
shortstop yeah they i i know but i mean
i honestly i know steinbrenner's are
made of money i don't know how much
money's left judge is going to have to
get the contract and the correa wants
that's going to be around the corner
they're already paying coal um and
stanton well i don't know
before i let you go uh john uh let's
talk rockets that just uh tipped off
their
2021 2022 campaign what is the what is
the expectation level for this team in
rebuilding mode right now they bottomed
out last year they ended up with second
pick in the draft got guard jaylen green
they're very young
we believe they'll be bad again and then
the rebuild will take take over next
season it's like the texans are
rebuilding now i contend why winning of
the game go ahead try to get the top
pick
but and then we saw what happened when
the astros bottomed out so expectations
are not high for the rockets right now
but if you think about all these young
guys it's like you have your child
and you didn't get them somewhere else
they were born here they're going to
stumble and they're going to bumble and
you're going to watch them grow and
that's kind of the attitude fans are
taking with the rockets john mclean
always appreciate uh connecting with you
um let's talk certainly down the line
it's going to be a a wild week i mean
there's no pr hit i guess anymore uh
trading desean watson in a week in which
your team's gonna go visit j.j watt and
deandre hopkins that
i guess strike the deal when you can if
they can right rich thank you very much
for having me as always always a
pleasure thank you john mclean houston
chronicle right here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here